mental health in schools it is a top
issue and a new survey showing 39
percent of CCSD students say they
sometimes stay home from school because
of anxiety 8 news now reporter Brian
will shows us what kind of resources are
offered to students and how a conference
is helping to spread the word mental
health basically to being in a still
mind you can handle the daily stress of
life and while doing so you become
productive and if you are productive and
the society that you live in becomes
productive Miracle Minds therapy offers
free therapy sessions to students
through grants sessions for CCSD
students have skyrocketed from 30 per
week to over 700 per week across 15
schools these students they're absentee
rate has gone down they are less
disruptive in the classroom their their
behavior has changed Ramona espara is a
former CCSD principal and has seen the
success of this therapy for firsthand
one of her students was threatening
self-harm but through the use of this
therapy he actually graduated and he
came back as a volunteer at times and
students and I would say that he's now
thriving this is Miracle mind therapy's
first school-based mental health
conference and they're hoping to end the
stigma around mental health especially
in schools dozens of Educators and staff
attended the conference on Tuesday to
encourage schools to prioritize mental
health and their schools we're not going
to see any kind of academic outcomes
progress if we don't address the social
and emotional needs of our students